[Music]
the last time Taylor hit the VMA sage
was in 2015 this year miss Swift's
nominated for ten awards she's tied with
ariana grande you'll see her sitting in
the front row when she's not on stage
look for communica Baio and Shawn Mendes
on the other side of the aisle the
couple set to perform their single
senorita live for the first time other
couples were hoping to see Nick and
Priyanka and Joe and Sophie the Joe Broz
are nominated for four awards and also
set to perform
[Music]
we were there today as they prepped for
the live show and couldn't help but
notice Gigi and Bella Hadid have an
empty seat between them maybe for Gigi's
new flame Tyler Cameron Billy Ray Cyrus
lil Nozick's and Liz O will all be there
too first time host comedian Sebastian
Maniscalco told us he's not stressing
over any of that the only person that
will give me nerves is my father and
he'll be here
dad's gonna be there I'm gonna be there
and this year we have a special position
for ET backstage at the VMAs so I'm
going to see all the craziness of
everyone coming on and off after the
performances so can't wait for Monday
[Music]